افتتح الحرس الثوري الايراني قاعده عسكريه
بحريه على مضيق هرمز قال القائد العام
للحرس الثوري انها تقع في اهم نقطه
استراتيجيه من الناحيتين الدفاعيه
والهجوميه في الخليج ومضيق هرمز واضاف ان
الهدف من القاعده هو الرقابه الكامله على
تحركات السفن في مضيق رمز والخليج وبحر
عمان
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ونناقش فيما
وراءه ما دلاله افتتاح الحرس الثوري قاعده
بحريه جديده على مضيق رمز وما الرساله
التي يحملها اختيار موقعها وتوقيت
افتتاحها وما هي الانعكاسات المحتمله لمثل
هذه الخطوه على امن واستقرار الخليج في ظل
المتغيرات التي تشهدها المنطقه
حاليا
بمشاركه القائد العام للحرس الثوري
الايراني اللواء حسين سلامي افتتح الحرس
الثوري قاعده عسكريه بحريه جديده في مدينه
سيريك على الجهه الشرقيه من مضيق هرمز
القاعده البحريه الجديده تقع بحسب قائد
الحرس الثوري في نقطه هي الاهم على
الاطلاق من الناحيه الاستراتيجيه فيما يخص
الشؤون الدفاعيه والهجوميه في مياه الخليج
ومضيق هرمز كما ان افتتاح القا يعد وفقا
للقائد العام للحرس الثوري الايراني نقله
نوعيه في مجال تنفيذ العمليات القتاليه
وعمليات الاستطلاع والدفاع في مياه الخليج
اما الهدف من انشائها فهو كما اكد اللواء
سلامي الرقابه الكامله على تحركات السفن
في مضيق هرمز والخليج وبحر
عمان افتتاح والقاعده البحريه الجديده
للحرس الثوري ياتي غدات كشف قائد قوات
البحريه علي رضا تغن سيري عن رصد الحرس
الثوري مطلع الاسبوع حامله الطائرات
الامريكيه يو اس اس نمت ومجموعتها
القتاليه قبل دخولها مضيق هرمز ومياه
الخليج ولم ينسى تنزير التاكيد في هذه
المناسبه على ما سماها قدره الحرس الثوري
على رصد كل التحركات البحريه في المنطقه
بواسطه طائراته
المسيره
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من طهران
عبر الانترنت الباحث المتخصص في القضايا
الاقليميه والاستراتيجيه حسين ريوان ومن
واشنطن ماثيو بروسكي الخبير في مجموعه
الدراسات الامنيه ومستشار فريق السلام في
اداره الرئيس ترامب ومن عمان الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي عمر عيسر وابدا بضيفي من
طهران السيد روران لاساله عن ما طرحناه في
بدايه هذه هذه الحلقه عن دلاله الاعلان عن
هذه القاعده عن اهدافها ودورها وعن توقيت
الاعلان
بالذات بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحياتي لك
ولضيوف الكرام والمشاهدين الاعزاء يعني
هذه
القاعده تم البدء في بنائها منذ عام 2014
وكانت هناك مهمه اعطيت للحرس الى جانب
الجيش الايراني
في
مواجهه
يعني من يهددون الامن خاصه في منطقه باب
المنب
وبحر العرب بحر عمان ضمن ه هذه الرؤيه تم
يعني البدء ببناء هذه القاعده وتم افتتاح
هذه القاعده يوم الاربعاء من قبل قائد
الحرس الثوري السيد
سلامي من هنا يعني الموضوع هو وليس وليد
اليوم هو وليد يعني
اي فتره سابقه وبرنامج عمل الحرس الثوري
يمتلك قاعده وماذا عن توقيت الاعلان عنها
الان سيد روران في ظل تصريحات المسؤولين
الايرانيين وعلى راسهم الرئيس الايراني
بان ايران لن تكون جزءا من اللعبه
الانتخابيه في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لن يتم اجبار ايران على الجلوس للتفاوض
بالتهديد او ب الحرب ماذا عن التوقيت في
ظل ايضا الخطوه الامريكيه بالتصعيد تصعيد
العقوبات وتصعيد الحظر على
ايران يعني في تصوري هي تحمل رساله مهمه
وهي ان ايران لن تتنازل عن دورها في
اي الدفاع عن مياهها الاقليميه وعن الامن
الاقليمي الذي تشكل ايران جزء كبير منه
يعني تصور من حدود باكستان الى مضيق هرمز
هذه المنطقه الحرس يمتلك قاعده واحده في
تبهار وهو يعني
اي الان هذه القاعده الثانيه في هذه
المنطقه عدا القواعد التي يمتلكها داخل
الخليج من هنا في تصوري ان الرساله الاهم
هي ان ايران مصره في الدفاع عن نفسها
ايران لازالت تحاول بناء ا يعني اي
مواقع القوه البحريه للدفاع عن نفسها امام
اي خطر يمكن ان يهددها سواء كان الرساله
الايرانيه اسال ضيفي من واشنطن السيد
ماثيو فيما يتعلق بما تريد واشنطن قوله
ضيفي يقول بان القاعده مبرمجه من العام
2014 وجود حامله الطائرات ممتس في مياه
الخليج ايضا في
ظل الوجود الدوري للقوات الامريكيه او
حمله الطائرات في المنطقه ام له رس راله
محدده هذه
المره طيب عندما ننظر للتوقيت هناك مجموعه
من الامور ينبغي الاشاره اليها
ايران قامت بمناورات عسكريه بحريه في
الاونه الاخيره الامارات والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه قامت ايضا في منطقه
هرمز
مناورات عسكريه يجب ان اقول او نسال او
نتساءل الى اين ترسل ايران هذه الرساله
بعدما قرت الامارات تطبيع العلاقات مع
اسرائيل في شهر
اغسطس قامت ايران
باحتجاز ناقله نفط اماراتيه وقامت ايران
تحديدا باختطاف تلك الناقله اذا رساله
ايران هي موجهه لاسرائيل للامارات
ولاي دوله حليفه للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
قالت باننا سنبقي على مضيق هرمز
مفتوحا اذا هناك رساله امريكيه محدده هذه
المره من خلال تواجد حامله الطائرات نمت
في مياه الخليج ما نوع هذه الرساله سيد
ماثيو
ك تتوفر على الاسو الخامس كما تعلمون
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه تتوفر على
اكبر قاعده عسكريه في المنطقه في قطر
وامريكا متواجده بشكل مستمر في المنطقه
وهي تقوم بنقل معداتها
و حاملات طائرات من مكان الى اخر اذا ليس
هناك رساله خاصه في الوقت الراهن ولكن نحن
نعرف ان ايران الان تشعر بالضغط المتزايد
عليها وهي منزعجه من انعزالها الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه دوما مستعده للدفاع عن
نفسها وعن حلفائها سيد عمر عيسر هل نحن
امام استعمال نفس الادوات من قبل الطرفين
واشنطن وطهران طبعا ادوات التلويح بالحرب
او الاستعداد العسكري او ان الوضع هذه
المره ام ان الوضع هذه المره يختلف من حيث
القراءه وربما ما قد
يطر يعني لا نستطيع ان نستبعد قصه استعراض
القوه نعم هناك استعراض القوه من كلا
الطرفين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تاتي
بحمله طائرات ثم ترد عليها ايران
با اعلان عن قاعده صحيح انها بدت منذ ست
سنوات لكن اختيار التوقيت له علاقه
باستعراض القوه هذا لا يمنع من وجود
مجموعه من الرسائل ارادت ايران ارسالها
الى اطراف متعدده ومتنوعه وانا هنا اتحدث
على ان ايران تريد ان تؤكد وترسل رساله
للمنطقه للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وللخلق العربي على ان مساله الهيمنه على
هرمز مساله مؤكده او تاكيد
للمؤكلات طبيع بمعنى رساله للدول التي
طبعت وجاءت باسرائيل هذا الدب الذي جيء به
الى المنطقه تريد اليوم ايران ان تقول
انها مستعده لكل ذلك رساله لترامب
والتوقيت الانتخابي ومحاوله تجديد
العقوبات على ايران من ناحيه منع
استيرادها للسلاح تريد ان تقول نحن بخير
ونستطيع ان ندشن قاعده قاعده بحريه بهذا
الحجم بتقديري كل هذه يمكن فهمها كرسائل
لكن الرساله الاعمق دلاله هي ان ايران
لازالت ترسل بمسجات واضحه انها قادره على
ان تنتج قوتها مره تلو الاخرى قادره على
ان تظهر عضلاتها مره والاخرى برغم كل
الظروف والحصار وكل هذه الاشكالات رغم
التطبيع والرسائل السلبيه التي تاتي من
دول المنطقه الا ايران الا ان ايران
لازالت تقول انا قادر على الاشتباك
العسكري بطريقه او اخرى وبتقديري ان
القيمه الفنيه لهذه القاعده ايضا لها
دلاله تتعلق بكل ما اشرت من رسائل سيد
ريان بناء على ما ذكر ضيفي قبل قليل من
واشنطن وربطه بين هذه الرسائل من قبل
طهران ومساله
التطبيع الاماراتي الاسرائيلي هل جزء من
الرساله الايرانيه ايضا يتعلق بهذا
التطور بشكل
مباشر يعني في تصوري نعم يعني عندما تقوم
ايران باستكمال قدراتها في المنطقه
واستعراضها هي ترسل هكذا رساله
لان يعني اي استدعاء الاسرائيليين من خلال
الاعتراف بالكيان الصهيوني من قبل
الامارات وكذلك البحرين هو بشكل او باخر
يخل بالمعادلات في المنطقه وايران من خلال
افتتاح هذ هذه القاعده الجديده التي يعني
تزيد تحكم ايران في مضيق رمز في تصوري هي
ارسلت هذه الرساله ولكن في تصوري ان الاهم
من هذا كله ان ايران تقوم بكل
هذه يعني الامور في ظل الحصار يعني اي
ايران رغم شح الموارد ورغم كل الظروف
السيئه بسبب الحصار الا ان ايران لا
تتساهل في موضوع سيادتها واستقلالها
والدفاع عن مياهها وترابها سيد بروكي وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي لوح مؤخرا بما سوف
تتخذه واشنطن من اجراءات من اجل تطبيق
اغلاق تام وفرض حظر ايضا اضافي على الجانب
الايراني وها هي اليوم طهران ترد من خلال
مضيق هرمز وبالتالي كيف تجد واشنطن هذه
الرساله من قبل
طهران
طيب انت سالت السؤال الوجيه والصائب
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الان تنظر الى
ما يحدث ايران قررت ان تعلن عن افتتاح هذه
القاعده التي ليست قاعده استثنائيه في
طبيعتها وربما الشيء الوحيد هو الموقع نعم
ايران ستفتتح قواعد على اراضيها وهذا شيء
طبيعي وايران ستستعرض عضلاتها وتح حول
اخافه امريكا وحلفائها ولكن الحقيقه هي ان
امريكا مازالت تراقب كل شيء يحدث في
المنطقه بمعيه الحلفاء نعلم ان ايران هددت
باغلاق مضيق هرموس ولاحظنا
بانهم انشاوا حوالي 1000 كتر من الانابيب
من اجل نقل النفط من دون حاجتهم الذهاب
عبر مض هرمز اذا نحن مدركون لما يقومون به
ولكن هذه اراضيهم بامكانهم بناء القواعد
لكن هذا لا يشكل خطرا حقيقيا
لامريكا ولا لحلفائه ولكن نحن بحضورنا في
المنطقه سندافع عن حقوقنا وان حقوق
حلفائنا اذا افتتاح الحرس الثوري قاعدته
البحريه الجديده على مضيق هرمز وقبال دوله
الامارات يدعو للتساؤل بشان مستقبل
استقرار الخليج بعد جلب اثنتين من دولها
احد اعداء ايران الرئيسيين الى المنطقه
وهنا اسال ضيفي السيد عمر عياصره فيما
يتعلق
ب هذه الخطوط المتداخله بين العلاقه
التاريخيه بين واشنطن وبين طهران منطقه
حساسه وحساسه جدا كل طرف فيها يستعمل
ادواته والخطوات الاخيره في التطبيع
والتحذير الايراني من هذا التطبيع وما قد
يطر على صعيد المنطقه حتى على صعيد اضافه
لبرام التفجير في المنطقه ما الذي ينتظر
المنطقه برايك مع هذه التطورات سيد
عمر يعني مزيد من الاجواء المشحونه نعم
يعني انا اتفق معك اتفاقا كاملا على ان ما
يجري في المنطقه غير عقلاني بمعنى التطبيع
الذي جرى وجذب اسرائيل وجلبها الى المنطقه
غير عقلاني التصعيد العسكري وهذا السباق
بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وبين
ايران هذا ايضا يقود المنطقه الى المجهول
عدم التفكير من كافه الاطراف بالذهاب الى
الطاوله الى التسويه الى الحوار الى
النقاش الى يعني تصفير المشاكل الى تصغير
قصه هذا التصعيد كلها قد يقود المنطقه الى
مرحله يعني قد تكون هاويه بمعنى انا ارى
ان المساله او الاجواء ملبده بالغازات
وتنتظر صاعق من ياتي بالصاعق هذه مساله
نتمنى ان لا تاتي لكن على ما يبدو ان
الاطراف في المنطقه ليسوا جادين بالتعامل
مع امن المنطقه الذاتي لازال هناك عامل
خارجي يتلاعب بالمنطقه وانا اقصد صد هنا
الوجود الولايات المتحده ومصالحها ومصالح
اسرائيل انا برايي اذا دخلت اسرائيل هذه
المنطقه ومصالحها بشكل مباشر ستصبح
المنطقه عرضه لتفجير يعني اكبر ولذلك اتفق
ان القلق سيزيد التوتر سيزيد والامر يحتاج
الى مزيد من العقلانيه لكن يبدو ان هذه
العقلانيه الان معلقه وبعيده
عن بصيره الجميع في المنطقه سواء ايران او
الخليج العربي او حتى الاير او حتى
الامريكي عن هذه العقلانيه اسال ضيفي من
طهران سيد روران ايران اكثر من مره ايضا
ارسلت رساله تحذير لدول المنطقه دول
بعينها خاصه بعد التطبيع الاسرائيلي مع
بعض دول
الخليج ضيفي من عمان سيد عمر يرى بان
العقلانيه تتراجع في المنطقه ايران ترسل
الرسائل هل من رد على هذه الرسائل وما
طبيعه هذا الرد في يعني في اطار تقارب ام
المسافه تبتعد شيئا فشيئا وبالتالي الوضع
يصبح اكثر تعقيدا سيد
روران
يعني اولا منطقه الخليج الفارسي بالنسبه
لايران هي منطقه استراتيجيه وحيويه الى
ابعد الحدود لماذا لان المنشات النوويه
الايرانيه في هذه
المنطقه ابار النفط في هذه المنطقه
الموانئ الايرانيه وحركه الاستيراد
والتصدير في هذه المنطقه من هنا من
الطبيعي جدا ان تقوم ايران بالدفاع عن
نفسها في هذه المنطقه كدفاع عن مصالحها
الحيويه نعم امريكا جاءت من اقاص الدنيا
الى هذه المنطقه وهي تحاول ان تستغل بعض
الدول وتحاول ان تبتز بعض الدول هذا شيء
اخر ولكن في تصور ما تقوم به ايران هو
عقلاني الى ابعد الحدود ولكن ما تقوم به
امريكا هو استفزازي وما يقوم تقوم به بعض
الدول في المنطقه وهنا اقصد الامارات
والبحرين في تصوري هو اللعب بالنار يعني
ايران اي قد يعني تقبل ان هناك قرارا
سياديا اماراتيا وبحريني ولكن لا يمكن ان
تقبل تهديد امنها القومي كما امريكا في
الستينات يعني عندما قامت كوبا بنفس هذا
الدور مع الاتحاد السوفيتي راينا امريكا
كادت ان تاخذ الدنيا الى حرب ثالثه من هنا
من حق ايران ان ترفض اي لعب بالامن القومي
وبالامل الاقليمي في المنطقه سيد بروسكي
بعض المراقبين يرون بان مؤشر فهم التصعيد
والتهدئه الامريكيه مع ايران مرتبط
بعاملين هذه الايام يتعلق بالانتخابات
الامريكيه القادمه والعامل الثابت او
العامل الثابت وما يتعلق باسرائيل ماذا عن
مصالح دول المنطقه وحمايتها وابعادها عن
هذه الحسابات سواء حسابات البيت الابيض او
الحسابات الامريكيه مع الطرف
الاسرائيلي
يمكن ان اقول هو ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لا تقبل
اطلاقا ما يحدث وفي حقيقه الامر هناك
استفزازات من قبل ايران وهذه الاستفزازات
لا تتصدر عناوين الاخبار هنا في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه واي صراع مع ايران لا
يساعد اداره ترامب في الانتخابات اذا ليس
هناك حسابات انتخابيه في هذا الخصوص وليس
من مصلحه ترامب ان يدخل في صراع عسكري
بالنسبه لاسرائيل
في الوقت الراهن هناك اطل في اسرائيل الى
جانب الاغلاق لمده اسبوعين بسبب الجائحه
بالتالي اعتقد هذه لعبه ايرانيه خالصه ولا
يكترث احد لما تقوم به ايران في الوقت
الراهن وهذا لا يغير من اللعبه سي هناك
ايضا من يرى من بعض المراقبين بانه نفس
عوامل الاشعال في المنطقه قد تكون هي
نفسها عوامل التهدئه ويعطونا بعض الامثله
يقولون جرى استهداف منشات نفطيه حساسه
بالنسبه للعالم في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه و واتهمت ايران ولم يحدث شيء
اسقطت طائره ولم يحدث شيء قتل قاسم
سليماني ولم تتطور الامور الى الاشتعال ال
الكامل هل يمكن المراهنه على هذه النظريه
او المقاربه في فهم ما قد يشعل المنطقه او
يضمن استقرارها والحسابات فيها على هذا
المنوال يعني نعم هناك ثابت يتعلق بانه
ايران والولايات المتحده الامريكيه لا
يرغبان بالتماس العسكري او بالمعركه
العسكريه والذهاب واللجوء الى الخيار
العسكري وجميع ما ذكرته انت يعني يثبت انه
من خلال التجربه والتتبع والاستقراء
نستطيع ان نقول ان جميع المحكات انتهت الى
تفكيك الازمه بدون الذهاب الى خيار عسكري
لكن بالمقابل التوتر والذهاب الى التصعيد
الى حافه الهاويه ثم الرجوع من الذي يخسر
اكثر دول المنطقه هي التي تخسر اكثر تخسر
باقتصادها وتخسر بوزنها وطبيعتها وتبتعد
اكثر عن امكانيه الذهاب باتجاه تسويه مع
الايراني اليوم هناك عامل اخر هو العامل
الاسرائيلي هل سيدخل في ذات السياق
والعلاقات مع الايراني بمعنى ستكون الخليج
خاسره امام علاقات جديده بين الاسرائيلي
والايراني هذا ربما سؤال مفتوح للنقاش في
قادم السنوات والايام لكن اريد فقط ان
اعقب على ما قاله ضيفي الكريم من طهران في
قصه عقلانيه ايران ايران ليست عقلانيه في
بعض الملفات عليها ان ترسل رسائل الطمنه
للمنطقه عليها ان تعيد انتاج دورها في
العراق وفي اليمن وفي سوريا حتى تطمئن
المنطقه اكثر صحيح ان فوبيا ايران في
المنطقه قد تكون اكبر من قصه طمانه ايران
لكن ارسال الرسائل الايرانيه الى المنطقه
بانها ترغب فعلا بعدم الاستيلاء
والاستحواذ والهيمنه على المنطقه ربما
يصنع مسافه بين المنطقه وبين الايراني بين
بين الامريكي والاسرائيلي على ايران ان
تبادر بذلك بقدر وعلى قدم وساق بقدرتها
على ارسال الرسائل العسكريه اين رسائلها
العقلانيه للمنطقه هذا سؤال كبير يحتاج
ربما الى هدوء ايراني والى موقف ايراني
مختلف ضيفي من طهران ان ان يجيبك على
تساؤلك هذا ولكن فقط اطرح سؤال وله بعد
ذلك ان يجيب على تساؤل السيد عمر عيسر من
عمان سيد روران بالعوده الى هذه القاعده
الايرانيه في هذه المنطقه الحساسه من مضيق
هرمز هي رساله موجهه بالاساس لواشنطن ام
لدول المنطقه لانه حتى ولو لم يحدث هناك
اي مواجهه عسكريه فهذا المضيق حساس
بالنسبه لممرات ناقلات النفط بالنسبه لدول
المنطقه وبالنسبه لاقتصاد النفط في العالم
بصفه عامه فهل ايضا جزء من الرساله جزء
اقتصادي موجه لدول
المنطقه يعني ايران لطالما قالت ان البنيه
الامنيه في المنطقه او النظام الامني يجب
ان يكون حصيله تعاون بين دول المنطقه
بعيدا عن تدخل القوى الكبرى من هنا رساله
ايران دائما لدول المنطقه هو التعاون في
المجال الامني ولكن هناك
يعني
اطراف لا تمتلك قرارها مع الاسف وامريكا
تدفع باتجاه يعني التعارض في المنطقه
وتوسيع الهوه بين ايران وبين باقي دول
المنطقه ولكن الرساله لامر واضحه والرساله
للكيان الصهيوني ايضا واضحه المعالم ايران
في هذا الاطار هي لا تمزح و قد يكون
السلوك الايراني في ضرب الطائره الامريكيه
عندما دخلت اجوائها او في ضرب قاعده عين
الاسد عندما قامت امريكا بعمليه ارهابيه
باغتيال الشهيد قاسم سليماني يعني هذه هي
تعكس سياسات ايران يعني الواضحه في انها
لن تسكت على ضيم وماذا عن سؤال ضيفي فيما
يتعلق بما يجب ان تقدمه ايران
كدليل تهدئه او عقلانيه كما قلت وقال ضيفي
من عمان فيما يتعلق بما يجري في العراق او
في اليمن على سبيل
المثال يعني انا اتفق مع السيد عياصره في
هذا الاطار اولا الان على
خلفيه ما قامت به الامارات
والبحرين من بناء علاقات مع الكيان
الصهيوني هناك انقسام واضح في المنطقه
امريكا تدفع باتجاه توسيع قاعده يعني
الائتلاف الذي
يحاول ان يتعامل مع الكيان الصهيوني
المنطقه الان بحاجه الى رساله عقلانيه
لبناء ائتلاف جديد وتحالف هو يعني يدافع
عن فلسطين وعن القضيه الفلسطينيه وعن الحق
الفلسطيني وفي تصوري ان هذا يمكن ان يكون
نقطه انطلاق لبناء تحالف جديد
بين كل الدول التي تدعم القضيه الفلسطينيه
سيد بروسكي ضيفي من
واشنطن واشنطن لم تحقق الاجماع فيما يتعلق
باستصدار قرار دولي بالابقاء على حذر
الاسلحه على ايران بهذه الخطوات العسكريه
والتلويح واشنطن بانها ستقوم بذلك ولو ان
كان بشكل منفرد كما قال وزير الخارجيه
بومبيو في وقت سابق كيف ستفعل ذلك دون ان
تصل المنطقه الى حاله الاشتعال سيد
ماثيو نعم الامر بسيط للغايه بدايه ما
تريد امريكا ان تقوم به وما قامت به قبل
ايام ان امريكا عادت لتفعيل العقوبات
والامريكيون لهم القوه والقدره للقيام
بذلك بقوه القانون
بقوه القرار الاممي الشيء الثاني امريكا
بامكانها ان تعمد لعقوبات احاديه الجانب
لمعاقبه اي طرف سيتعامل تجاريا مع ايران
عندما يتعلق الامر
ب الاور المتعارضه مع القرارات السلفه
القرارات التنفيذيه التي اتخذها الرئيس
الامريكي دونالد ترامب تسمح لنا ل متابعه
ومساله الاشخاص الذين يساعدون ايران حتى
قبل توصيل اي من الم
هذه القرت تعطي لامريكا الكثير من الوسائل
والادوات لل فيما يخص ما قاله ضيفكم من
طهران هذه امور بعيده عن الواقع الدول ذات
السياده بامكانها ان تعقد تحالفات مع
الدول التي تريد ايران تحاول ان تسيطر على
لبنان اليمن والعراق وسوريا
وكل في المنطقه يعرف هذه الامور بشكل بشكل
واضح اعتقد ما يقوله ضيفكم هو شيء بعيد عن
الواقع ويقول بان من يريد الايرانيون يق
فقط من اجل مصلحه العرب من واشنطن ماثيو
بروسكي الخبير في مجموعه الدراسات الامنيه
ومستشار فريق السلام في اداره الرئيس
ترامب شكرا جزيلا لك وكذلك لضيف من طهران
عبر الانترنت حسين روران الباحث المتخصص
في القضايا الاقليميه والاستراتيجيه وكذلك
ليفي من عمان عمر عيسر الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي ختام هذه الحلقه من ما وراء الخبر
نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه جديده في ما
وراء خبر جديد الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء